Hey, Office Ladies listeners! Hello there! Happy holidays! We want to wish everyone a Merry Christmas, a happy holiday, and let you know that we are off this week and next. Yeah, guys. We want to hang out with our families, you know, get in some fun time with the kiddos, and we hope you're having a great time with your family as well.
嘿，《办公室女士》的听众们！大家好！节日快乐！我们要祝大家圣诞快乐、假期愉快，并告诉大家我们这周和下周要休息。是的，伙计们。我们想和家人在一起，你知道的，和孩子们度过一些有趣的时光，我们也希望你和你的家人过得非常愉快。
I am going to attempt to make my very first panatone. Do you know what panatone is, Angela? Jenna, I don't know what that is. So you had mentioned it, so I googled it, and it looks like a very fancy bread? Yes, it is a spiced holiday bread. It has dried fruit in it. It takes about two days to make. Okay.
我打算尝试制作我的第一个潘妮托妮（意大利水果面包）。安吉拉，你知道什么是潘妮托妮吗？珍娜，我不知道那是什么。你之前提过，所以我谷歌了一下，它看起来像是一种非常高级的面包？是的，它是一种香料节日面包。里面有果干。制作大约需要两天时间。好吧。
So a year ago on Christmas, I went to my friend Lindsay's house, and she served a panatone. Didn't you say Lindsay though? It's like always in like a ball gown, but always has amazing food. This is a very put-together person. Yes. She recommended that cleanse that I went on. She also serves amazing holiday bread. She's my goals, basically.
所以一年前的圣诞节，我去了我朋友琳赛家，她端出了潘妮托妮。不过你刚才说的是琳赛吗？她总是像穿着晚礼服一样，但总能做出惊人的美食。这是一个非常完美、有条理的人。是的。她推荐了我去尝试的那个排毒轻体疗程。她还会端出惊人的节日面包。基本上她就是我的偶像。
And this started me on my bread-making journey. It's my one-year anniversary of baking homemade bread. Even my bread-making teacher, Bonnie O'Hara, told me she will not make panatone because it's too difficult. She said she made it once, and she'll never make it again, but I am determined. I'm going to take it on. I'm going to make a panatone this year. So for the holidays, this is like our kids' wish list.
这开启了我的面包制作之旅。这是我烘焙自制面包的一周年纪念。连我的面包制作老师邦尼·奥哈拉都告诉我，她不会做潘妮托妮，因为它太难了。她说她做过一次，再也不会做了，但我下定决心了。我要挑战它。我今年一定要做一个潘妮托妮。所以对于假期，这就像是我们孩子们的愿望清单。
They want to see Star Wars. Okay. So we're going to go see Star Wars. They want to go to an escape room. Oh, they're so fun, Angela. Is it scary? No. Well, you have to pick the right one.
他们想看《星球大战》。好的。所以我们要去看《星球大战》。他们想去密室逃脱。哦，那太有趣了，安吉拉。会很吓人吗？不。嗯，你得选对主题。
I don't want to scare it. This is like with our kids. I just want to be fun. They have some that are special for kids. Okay. You have to, I'll send you a link. Will you? Yes.
我可不想被吓到。这是和孩子们一起去的。我只想玩得开心。有些密室是专门为儿童设计的。好的。你必须，我发个链接给你。你会吗？会的。
Okay, so they really want to do an escape room. And then Jenna, I'm glad you're sitting down because I'm going to make bread. What? Okay. You're going to make bread? I'm going to make bread because, okay. So our family came out at Thanksgiving. Josh's sister makes this rosemary bread from scratch.
好吧，所以他们真的很想玩密室逃脱。然后珍娜，我很高兴你坐下来了，因为我要做面包。什么？好吧。你要做面包？我要做面包，因为，好吧。感恩节时我们全家出动了。乔希的姐姐亲手做了这种迷迭香面包。
It's so good. And she showed me how to do it. But as you know, I don't have a ton of patience with any kind of baking or crafting. And this takes like two days. And I don't, you're making a two day bread. I'm making a two day bread. And I'm making a two day bread. Lady.
太好吃了。她教我怎么做。但如你所知，我对任何烘焙或手工都没什么耐心。而这个需要大约两天时间。而且我，你在做一个需要两天的面包。我在做一个两天的面包。我也在做一个两天的面包。天哪。
And we didn't even plan it. We didn't. That's best friendship right there. Guys, we'll be back on January 8th with the fire. But if you can't get enough office ladies, head over to Stitcher Premium for our candy bag episodes. So this is where we answer more of your questions and we discuss all the things that you think we missed in our original podcast, which apparently is a lot.
而且我们甚至都没有提前计划。确实没有。这就是最棒的友谊。伙计们，我们将在1月8日带着精彩内容回归。但如果你觉得《办公室女士》听不过瘾，可以去 Stitcher Premium 收听我们的糖果袋特辑。在这里，我们回答你们更多的提问，并讨论所有你们认为我们在原版播客中漏掉的事情，显然有很多。
Oh yeah. We get, we get like people writing in, but we're actually loving it because we're finding that it's opening up a whole new conversation for us. So go check out our candy bag because we really sort of dive into your questions. This week we answer some general fan questions and we play you the rest of our call with office prop master Phil Shea. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code office. And we will also have a special New Year's treat for you, so watch out for that in this
哦，是的。我们收到了很多人的来信，但我们其实很喜欢，因为我们发现这为我们打开了一个全新的对话空间。所以快去看看我们的糖果袋特辑吧，因为我们真的会深入探讨你们的问题。本周我们回答了一些粉丝的常规问题，并播出了我们与办公室道具师菲尔·谢a通话的剩余部分。如需免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 office。我们还为您准备了特别的新年惊喜，请在这个订阅源中留意。
feed. Merry Christmas. Happy Holidays. Merry Christmas. And Birthday Christmas boy y'all. Bye. Bye now. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
圣诞快乐。节日快乐。圣诞快乐。还有生日圣诞男孩们，再见。再见啦。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。